failed former vice president Mike Pence
one of the least charismatic members of
the Republican party of note of the last
decade says that history is going to
hold Donald Trump accountable for
January 6th maybe history will hold
Trump accountable but Mike Pence doesn't
seem interested in Trump actually being
held accountable now in any kind of
legal way Mike Pence is saying that
Donald Trump endangered his family on
January 6 2021 that is true Mike Pence
and his family were endangered by Donald
Trump in 2021 but Pence is still sort of
playing Coy with whether there should be
actual consequences prosecution or
whatever the case may be here's my
question to you do you think at this
point
that Donald Trump is going to be
indicted in any of the investigations
going on or do you think that he is
going to get away with it let me know in
a comment